the initial response to the Empire
Strikes Back is eerily similar to that
of 2017's episode 8 The Last Jedi both
middle chapters of their respective
trilogies tried to take the Star Wars
franchise in exciting New Directions and
both received mixed reviews from fans
who were initially displeased with the
wide gap between their expectations and
the film itself many fans slammed the
Last Jedi for its diversity in addition
to critiquing the coherence of its plot
there were similar complaints about the
story not being coherent or compelling
about The Empire Strikes Back the Last
Jedi writer and director Ryan Johnson
admitted that even he himself was
initially disappointed with Empire which
was actually the first Star Wars movie
he remembered seeing however he
eventually came to a senses saying that
after watching and loving Return of the
Jedi he wound up warming to Empire in
fact it gradually became his favorite of
the trilogy